[Music]
so I'm thrilled to be here today and
when I was looking at my briefing sheet
and I saw that the title of the series
is a view from the top I thought well I
guess I've been on the top of an
organization before so I can give some
insights on that but I thought what
would be interesting is that I've also
sort of been trampled and on the ground
with people's feet on my head
looking up so maybe I could give a
perspective from that vantage point as
well you do not want to hear me give a
big long speech and I am NOT gonna do
that I'm gonna reserve most of the time
for for a Q&A but in thinking about
leadership I was sort of reflecting and
I thought okay what would I want to
share with young people who are in
undergrad or graduate school today and
there are three things through my
experiences in DC and now with students
first that I think could be helpful not
in telling you specifically what you
should do or not do but just to give you
a sense of perspective so three things
very simple the first this is actually
this is a lesson that I learned when I
was the Chancellor and it was one that
came to me from a mentor and hero of
mine Joel Klein so Joel used to be the
the Chancellor of the New York City
school system and long before I was
working in DC the mayor of DC and the
council members were trying to figure
out whether they wanted to move to a
mayoral control model or not so they
took a trip to New York they met with
Joel Klein and Mike Bloomberg they
toured the schools they sort of saw what
was going on there and at the end of
that visit Adrian Fenty said to Joel
Klein okay I want somebody like you to
come and run the schools in DC can you
give me a recommendation and Joel
actually ended up recommending me for
the job and because of that he always
felt this incredible
sense of guilt and so he would call me
and kind of you know check up on me all
the time so I remember one evening in
the height of sort of my first hundred
days when things were really getting a
little tough I was driving home one
night it's raining outside it's like a
11 o'clock at night and my phone rings
and I look at it and I see that it's
from Joel Klein so I pull over to the
side of the road answer the phone and I
said yes sir
and he said hey dude Michele I said I'm
doing okay it's a little tough right now
you know but I'm hanging in there he's
like he's like that's good he said I am
calling to give you some advice and I
said okay I am ready and he said oh
there are two things that I want to
communicate to you tonight I said okay
I'm ready let's go he said the first one
he said do you have a boyfriend
and I said no cuz at the time I did not
and he said okay so my first piece of
advice is go out and get one and I said
okay I did not think that I would be
ever getting love life advice from Joel
Klein so I sort of hesitatingly you know
said okay sir and he said he's like
here's what you need to understand he
said this job is one of the loneliest
jobs you could possibly have he said
every day is just an absolute grind he
said I would never be able to do what I
do every day if I didn't have my wife at
home cuz at the end of every tough day I
get into bed and she goes baby don't
worry about it
you're not the crazy ones they're the
crazy ones you are okay he said if I
didn't have that grounding me every day
I would not be able to wake up every
morning and go to work he said so my
first piece of advice is go and find a
boyfriend I said okay I accidently
meanwhile did do that and happily so
I've listened to that piece and then the
second thing he said he sort of got
really quiet and serious and he said so
here's my second thing he said you have
to lead from the front and he said it
with such conviction and confidence that
I said okay I
got it and I hung up the phone and I
pull back onto the road and I'm thinking
I have no idea what that means right but
I didn't want to I didn't want to ask
him any questions so they knew one I see
oh my god was stupid so I get back on
the road and it actually wasn't until
several months later that I had sort of
lived through a lot of the turmoil of
the of being the Chancellor that I
actually realized what he meant right
because when you are a leader sometimes
you've got to be out in front you can
see things that that other people can't
see at the time and if you get mired in
the muck if you sort of get you know
pulled into every single argument on one
side or another you're actually not
gonna be able to move your organization
as far as you can as fast as you can so
when he gave me that piece of advice I
was actually in the middle of our school
closure process which was incredibly
painful you know we had 144 schools we
were closing 23 of them was 15 percent
of the schools and if you ever want to
quickly become the most unpopular person
in a city all you have to do is tell
somebody that you're closing a school
much less 23 schools so I was in the
middle of this and it was it was just a
tremendous amount of opposition and
pushback and the interesting thing was
about a year after we closed the schools
and we went through that process I was
in one of the schools that had been
consolidated and I was trying to check
out you know what the situation was a
woman came up to me she said hey hey hey
look at me you recognize me
she said I was the one last year that
was always screaming at you about
closing the schools I said oh yeah I
know who you are I could never forget
that face she's like you know what I
just wanted to let you know you were
right she's I didn't we couldn't see it
at the time because it was such an
emotional and sentimental process for us
we were just angry at you and you know
this whole process she's like but now I
get it cuz we're in this school and a
school has a lot more resources our kids
are getting a better education so I'm
good and she walks away and I'm thinking
where's the Washington Post when this
kind of stuff happens right
but what I realize is this we were we
were able to because we made that
incredibly tough decision to close those
schools we were able to create a new
reality for the children Washington DC
because of that decision we were able to
provide an art music an art teacher a
music teacher a PE teacher a librarian a
nurse and a social worker or guidance
counselor at every single school in the
city for the first time in the history
that anybody could ever remember we
equalized the resources so that having
an art teacher wasn't dependent on
whether you you know we're at one of the
schools that had wealthier parents than
they could hold an auction the higher
the teacher etcetera we equalize the
playing field for all of the kids as it
pertained to the kinds of curriculum
that they should have and had we got
caught up in all of the sort of emotion
and the sort of opposition and whatnot
we would not have been able to follow
through on this decision and we could
not have provided the kids with those
additional resources so that's my first
message is sometimes you got to lead
from the front my second observation and
and you could you see that take my
advice or not on this one but I believe
very strongly that in order to be an
effective leader you have to be okay
with not being liked and I'm like really
really good at this one so you have you
can you can you can take my advice I I
remember very clearly about halfway
through my second year as Chancellor a
columnist for The Washington Post wrote
a piece and it was sort of you know I
like Michelle Rhee she is doing you know
good things and making hard decisions I
just wish she would be a little nicer so
I've read the piece and I'm pissed off
so I call like I'm like what are you
doing and he's like no you don't
understand he's like I want you to be
here for the long haul I think you are
good for the system he said but in order
for you to be here people got to like
you a little bit more you could be a
little friendlier a nicer and I like you
know sort of said him I said look you
have to figure out what you think the
most
characteristics of a school's chancellor
are and quite frankly if it's sort of
personality driven then you know and you
want warm and fuzzy then I am Not sure a
girl and you should actually be
advocating for my ouster but if you like
what is going on in the schools if you
believe sincerely that the right
decisions are being made in the
interests of kids then you should not be
saying Michelle Rhee needs to change her
personality you should be advocating
that we kind of leave the personalities
I didn't focus on the policies of what's
actually happening in the schools so I
say this because you know when I was in
my first year as the Chancellor my
mother came to town so when your mom
comes to tell you you got a whole
different perspective on things so my
mom happened to come at a time where
people were very very angry at me and so
she comes into town it was around the
school closure stuff and she you know
opens up the Washington Post there's a
two-page spread on you know all the
different schools that I'm closing like
pinpointed all over the city
she turns on the TV there people like
you know throwing things at me at a
meeting and that sort of thing she over
the weekend said there you know there's
some really loud people down the block
who are picketing about something I said
yeah they're picketing me she was like
oh my gosh I can't believe this is going
on so anyways one night at the end of a
long night of community meetings that I
was having I come home I'm in the
kitchen I'm making myself a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich my mother sort
of creeps into the kitchen and she says
are you okay I said yeah I'm fine I'm
good she looks at me she goes you know
when you were little you never used to
care what people thought about you she's
like so I always thought that you were
gonna grow up to be really antisocial
but I see now that this is serving you
well
I said yes it was because the bottom
line is that if you are concerned in too
strong away with being liked with
whether or not you're popular with what
your polling numbers look like etc then
you're gonna make a different set of
decisions and the bottom line is that no
really significant change comes without
some pretty significant pushback in
opposition as well and at the end of the
day if the decisions that you're making
are the ones that you believe are right
and you you you you you you have the
confidence of that then you have to be
okay getting that opposition getting the
criticism and at the end of the day not
being liked so much so that's my second
piece of advice my third is actually
about my boss at the time when I was in
DC Adrian Fenty who was the mayor of DC
did he's the person that I reported to
and in my opinion he is the person
without whom none of what we did in DC
could have happened he was an
extraordinarily unique politician in
that when he hired me he said all I want
you to do is make the schools better
make the schools a place where we want
to send our own children every day in
terms of politics and the push back and
what I'll handle that but we're not
gonna worry about it because at the end
of the day we're gonna make every
decision within what we believe is in
the best interest of kids he said that
on day one to me and of all the crazy
things that happened to me in DC
actually none of that was particularly
surprising the one thing that I would
say was surprising to me is the fact
that that man never wavered one time in
fact this is a quick story
his primary election was in September of
2010 and in August we had just
implemented a new teacher evaluation
system where for the first time we were
evaluating teachers based in part on
whether or not their student achievement
levels had grown in the school and so we
had identified a couple of hundred
people
who were were categorized as ineffective
and based on the the framework and the
structure that we had set out we said
that those people who had been rated as
ineffective after their first year were
subject to termination but this is weeks
away from his primary election so I call
the man and I say okay mayor so here's
where we are I reminded him about the
new evaluation system I said you know
the decision is whether we actually you
know move forward with these
terminations or not because at the end
of the day I am very sensitive to the
fact that you've got a race coming up I
don't want to do anything to jeopardize
your ability to to you know run the city
effectively etc and he said let me ask
you a question he said if we take this
action will that ensure that kids in DC
have better teachers income fall and I
said yes he's and then we got to do it I
said really he said absolutely because
every other political calculus that we
make we don't know what the outcome is
gonna be right so if we don't make this
decision does that mean I'm gonna win
the election can't we can't tell and
that's not really at the end of the day
what matters it's not why we're here
we're here to make sure that the kids
are getting a great education and if you
can tell me that by removing these
people and bringing you another ones
that kids are gonna get a good education
then I'm okay with that
so it was exactly the answer that I
wanted to hear it was not so much the
answer that other people wanted to hear
so we made the decision and you know the
city goes nuts right and I started
getting calls from people all throughout
the state people who were supporters of
the mayor and mine saying are you insane
this is political suicide you can't fire
a bunch of people weeks before the
election and it was amazing to me how
despite the fact that he was being told
that his political career was
potentially gonna end with this decision
the ease and the confidence with which
he made it because he knew that it at
the end of the day it was the right
policy decision to make I wish I could
say the same for politicians across this
country and elected officials across
this country we live in a state where
there is to say a lack of political
courage is an understatement we live in
a state where not too many months ago
when it was found that in an LAUSD in
Los Angeles there was a teacher who had
been a sexual predator I'm kind of
molesting kids etc a state assemblyman
from LA introduced a piece of
legislation and all it would have done
is made it easier for school districts
to fire people who were sexual predators
it's a pretty low bar in my opinion that
bill didn't even make it out of
committee couldn't even go to the floor
of the legislature for a vote because
the status quo people and you know folks
who wanted to defend you know the adult
interests etc said that the politicians
don't vote for this etc etc couldn't
even get a bill like that out of
committee a couple of weeks ago we had a
similar situation where a legislator
introduced a bill around teacher
evaluation in the state it was a very
very low-key bill it just said three
things one that parents and the
community should have input into the
evaluation two that we should evaluate
teachers and put them into four
different performance bands as opposed
to just satisfactory or unsatisfactory
and that for veteran teachers we would
move the timeframe so instead of
evaluating them once every five years we
could evaluate them once every three
years the committee vote of nine
committee members six of them abstained
abstained which is to me I was like look
if you don't like the bill for whatever
reason then vote against it but what I'm
stating all about so our our we had a
bunch of students first members at the
at the Capitol and they were asking one
of the people who had abstained well you
know why don't you take a stance on this
I mean what do you believe about it
whether it's right or wrong and you
agree with us nada but you have to take
a stand and the guy
said well here's the thing I've heard
from people constituents in my community
on both sides and so no matter what
happens there's gonna be one group of
people that's unhappy and so I don't
want to be in the middle of that but
that's your job right your job is to
hear from both sides what the pros and
cons of something like this and then to
make a decision that you believe is in
the public interest right that is going
to serve your constituents best whether
or not people get angry at you that
can't play into the calculus hardly the
profiles of courage that you would like
to see from your elected officials so at
the end of the day my third point and
potentially one of the most important is
you have to as a leader have the courage
of your convictions you have to know
what it is that you believe is right and
then you have to be willing to stake
everything essentially on it whether
it's your job where you're saying an
office so many of these politicians like
well here's the thing if I take this
vote then these people are not gonna
like me these people won't vote for me
next up and the world is a better place
if I remain in office and what I would
argue is the world is only a better
place if you're in office if you're
actually making the decisions that you
think are right for your constituents if
not and you're just you know trying to
determine which way the political winds
are blowing that's actually not moving
us forward in the right direction so
having the courage of your convictions
is my third but at the end of the day
here's what I believe and I'm take
questions and you can ask me anything
you want here's why I feel these three
lessons as it pertains to this
incredibly important field of education
is so important because public education
is supposed to be the great equalizer in
this country it is supposed to be the
thing that ensures it doesn't matter if
you're black or white rich or poor we
have a public education system so that
every single kid can have an equal shot
in life right you work hard you do the
right thing you can live the American
dream unfortunately that is not the
reality for the for a huge percentage
of kids in our country today in fact in
America today America is towards the
bottom internationally on social
mobility which means that if you are a
child who was born into poverty in this
country the likelihood that you will
ever escape poverty is slim to none
why because if you live in a poor
community with not a lot of resources
the likelihood is very high that you
attend a failing school and that you
will not gain the skills and knowledge
that you need to be able to go on to
higher education get a high paying job
etc so we are essentially saying to poor
kids now you don't have a shot in life
because of the circumstance of your
birth that in my opinion is the most
terrifying dynamic that we have going on
in this country today it goes against
every single ideal that we stand for as
a nation we are supposed to be the land
of equal opportunity where anybody can
pull themselves up by their bootstraps
if you have the the wherewithal the the
the will right you can do this but if we
are ensuring that essentially we are
keeping poor kids trapped in failing
schools where they're not getting the
education they deserve and then they
can't live that life what does that say
about us as a nation I would argue that
it is everything that we don't want to
say it goes again it goes against
everything that we stand for and that is
why if we are to focus on one issue in a
in a collective and bipartisan way in
this country it has to be this topic
every single person in this room plays a
role in this unless you stand up for
kids then we can't expect that anything
anything is ever gonna change ok that is
the end of my remarks and then I will
take questions
okay I think we have two people with
Mike so I'll just go back and forth over
there's the first so thank you for
coming my name is Jamal I'm a second
year MBA student I want to challenge you
a little bit on the the notions that the
idea of being friendly versus being
tough we spend a lot of time here
studying the interpersonal intricacies
and making tough decisions and something
I've come to learn is that there is a
lot of middle ground sometimes and I
wonder when you reflect upon your time
in DC do you ever think that had you
moderated your personality your
toughness you might have been more
effective I mean for example you fired
principals on TV and I know you've said
you regret that in hindsight but if
that's indicative of kind of your
general disposition do you feel like you
ever did a disservice to students by
being tough to a fault so here's what
what I said is you you you you have to
be okay with not being liked I didn't
say you got to be an a-hole right and
here's and there's a difference between
those two things so I would go out all
the time out into the community and and
you know one of the things that I would
often do is sort of speak to large
crowds of folks or I would do livingroom
meetings where you know a constituent
could invite me in to meet with you know
twelve or fifteen of their neighbors
that often times after those kinds of
meetings people would say wow you're
nothing like we thought you were gonna
be like you're actually kind of funny
and charming you know so I can win
people over and I you know I tried to do
plenty of that but at the end of the day
the question is what is more important
what was more important to me being
liked and being popular or doing the
right thing for kids and I remember I
don't know if any of you saw the movie
Waiting for Superman but there's a scene
in that movie where I'm in a I'm in a
community meeting where people are like
going nuts and apparently I have this
look on my face that's sort of serene
looking so people ask me all the time
like what were you thinking because you
know people are yelling at you and
calling you every name in the book and
like you look so calm so trying to
literally think back to like what was my
mindset right and at the end of the day
I actually know what was going through
my head which was we are living in a
city
we're 8% of the eighth graders are
operating on grade level in mathematics
eight percent 92 percent of our kids do
not have the skills and knowledge
necessary to be productive members of
society and we have to do something
radical to change that you may not like
it you can scream at me all you want but
I am NOT gonna let this continue on my
watch
so I'm good with you know be if you can
go out there and and and win people over
absolutely you should try but if that
becomes your goal right that becomes the
outcome that you're seeking that's what
I think is problematic so thanks for
coming to Stanford the question I ask is
how do you take your values and
translate them into school financing and
I'm thinking about you're in Sacramento
the State Treasurer invests a ton of
money through banks is there an
opportunity for social impact bonds or
some other financing mechanism that
would have a little more rationality
let's say than the budgeting process in
the capital because let's be clear the
current budgeting process is the least
rational process around so here's here's
the the bottom line should we bring some
some reason and ration to how we spend
money in schools absolutely a hundred
percent it is much more difficult than
you think it would be for a number of
reasons first is what is widely sort of
known and touted and talked about in
this country and in fact if you go to
any school district board meeting around
this time which is budgeting time what
you're gonna hear anywhere across the
country is what we need in order to fix
the system is more money but actually
the data doesn't bear that out right the
data shows that over the last two to
three decades in this country we have
more than doubled and almost tripled the
amount of money that we're spending per
kid in public education that's
controlling for inflation and yet the
results have remained pretty much
stagnant we we are spend
more money per kid than almost any other
OECD nation out there and yet again the
results are not where we would want them
to be I can tell you from having led a
school system where we were spending
more money per kid than any almost any
other jurisdiction in the entire nation
that people still were saying we need
more money we need more money and when I
looked at the budget we were spent we
had a 1 billion dollar budget when I got
to DC and of that 403 million of it was
going into the classroom in the schools
that means the majority was being sucked
up by this bureaucratic bloated
bureaucracy we had no idea there's no
accountability etc and so when you talk
to people in California today you'll
hear some similar things like if you go
out any to any school or any
superintendent and ask them how much
money do we spend in California per kid
you will get an answer of somewhere
between fifty five hundred and sixty
five hundred dollars that's what people
will tell you actually that is not
correct in this state we are spending
about ninety five hundred dollars per
kid per year on education those people
are actually not wrong because there's a
whole lot of money that they never see
in the schools because it gets lopped
off the top and put towards our unfunded
pension liabilities etc in fact unfunded
pension liabilities are a huge problem
across the country there's just a piece
of research that showed that just
funding unfunded pension liabilities in
a place like pencil in Philadelphia
right now is costing that district
between two and three thousand dollars
per kid per year we got to fix that
problem because until we fix that we
can't say there's not enough money it's
just the where the money is going so
what we believe in is advocating for
transparency as it pertains to the to
the dollars now this is an interesting
one because I was just in Ohio the other
day and we were advocating for
transparency of dollars and what we
found was that there was a school
district in the state of Ohio that was
spending more money per kid on their
cheerleading program than on their
literacy programs I kid you not
and I thought this is actually a good
data point
because I can't tell you that in that
community those people wouldn't say yes
cheerleading is so important I grew up
in Ohio so I know people like their
cheerleading the community might have
said yes we evaluate leading more highly
than literacy in which case then okay so
be it but I would bet that there would
be a whole lot of people who would say
wait a second this is crazy and we got
to change that but until you have the
data to show where the dollars are going
and what kind of return on investment
you're getting for those dollars there
it's gonna be very difficult to advocate
for the changes that we need and it's I
think it's always gonna devolve down
into let's just meet you know let's just
ask for more money I'm not against more
money let me be clear I'm just saying
that you have to use the dollars that
you have right now well before in
increased dollars we're going to have a
significant return on investment I
thanks so much for being here with us I
had a question on there there are many
areas in ad reform many different angles
that you could you could attack the
issue with and I'm wondering where are
you seeing the most like where are you
most excited about is it like federal
federal level state level district level
or is it charters or other kind of
groups like your own that you're
currently leading Thanks
so I would say this one of the the
challenges that we face in education
reform is that everybody is looking for
the silver bullet solution right so I on
a monthly basis I'll get calls from
governor's across the country saying
okay Michelle I'm gonna take education
on tell me the one thing that I should
do and usually I refuse to answer that
question because I say there is no one
thing that you can do that is going to
change education in your state it is
much too simplistic a mindset to go in
to this with so take students first for
example my new organization we focus on
three areas we don't think they're the
only three areas they're just the ones
that we focus on its principal and
teacher quality we focus on empowering
parents with information and choices and
we focus on fiscal accountability and
responsibility
within those three areas there are 37
different policies on our agenda and our
belief is that you have to have all 37
in place in order to create the kind of
environment that's gonna be ripe for
real reform to take place but what
people want to do is just choose one so
somebody will say well I'm gonna pass
the parent trigger where I believe in
vouchers and then they believe that you
know you implement a voucher program and
then all of a sudden everything's gonna
change because the market is gonna rule
it just doesn't work that way
so part of I think what we have to focus
on is understanding that how the the
system became the way that it is was
very sort of a complex mix of issues all
sort of coming together and how we're
gonna solve this problem is also a
complex mix of lots of different things
happening it's not just about one issue
or one policy yes
hi I'm Jenny thanks for being here I
appreciate your talking about leading
from the front and being willing to take
risks to not always be popular another
part of leadership that I I'm trying to
think about is how do you make sure that
you're as inclusive as you can be and
really build a cohesive movement so I'm
wondering if you could talk about how
you think about balancing those two
theme things and one of those maybe been
a time in your leadership where you've
decided to slow down or back off from
one of your goals in order to bring more
people along with you yeah that's a
great question and and something that to
tell you the truth we weren't able to do
particularly effectively in DC so but
this is the lesson that I learned from
that when we when I was in DC and we
were implementing all of these
incredibly aggressive reforms we were
out in the community at time I mean I
every single night we held Chancellor's
policy forums I had office hours I was
doing living room visits I did you know
teacher talks twice a week I mean we
were out there trying to engage the
community in what in in our reform
efforts getting their feedback etcetera
so at the end of the day it didn't work
we were not able to create an
environment where people felt that they
were part of what we were creating
and so it's interesting because people
say to me well this is that that shows
that you know you can't bring people
along and like no it doesn't what it
shows is that I wasn't successful at it
but just because I couldn't do something
I would never say that therefore it
can't be done right so what I would hope
is that the next superintendent who
comes along whether it's in DC or
somewhere else would be able to look at
what we did the things that we did well
and the things that we didn't do
particularly well and then learn from
those things and build off of them to
try to chart a new course like that's
what I think the most important thing
was so striking that balance I do think
is important and it was unfortunately
something that we were never able to
like do exactly the way that we wanted
to do I think that had we been able to
stay for another term for four more
years
I do believe strongly that that dynamic
would have changed because for us
because what we were doing was so
dramatic and we were doing it in such
short order we were getting that kind of
immediate you know opposition and and
pushback that often you do when you have
significant change what we weren't able
to stay there for was people realizing
wait okay it's not so bad like yes we
have a new teacher evaluation system but
now I'm getting paid a whole lot more
money because I'm effective in the
classroom you know the sky didn't fall
etcetera so you know but those things
have to be in place for some time before
people can come around to it and I think
that's just a virtue of you know also
sort of leadership and knowing that that
consistency is important too and I think
one of the most fortunate things about
my experience in DC is that the woman
who was my deputy was able to continue
on and she is now the Chancellor in DC
so there was a tremendous amount of
consistency within the policies that we
were pushing but the dynamics are
different than I think that she's she's
she's doing a great job of that now yes
hi my name is Katie I'm a first year MBA
so I wanted to ask you about some of the
erasure scandals that have been
happening nationally over the last few
years as you know as there's been
increased accountability linked with
high-stakes testing that's also kind of
been tied with teacher cheating
administrative teaching
New York DC Texas and across the country
I'm wondering as a leader how you kind
of we're within this cycle you see the
root cause beyond simply blaming the
individuals involved yeah so I'd say
this that I believe very strongly that
the vast majority of educators in this
country would never ever compromise
their personal or professional integrity
and cheat on a test cuz they know that
that's cheating kids and they would
never do that does that mean that there
aren't a small number of people out
there who are gonna make the wrong
decision no you're always gonna have
that circumstance and I think that
because of that you need to be very
clear with folks about the fact that
cheating is unacceptable you have to
have very strong test security measures
in place and then when it does happen
and you find that as happens then you
have to have consequences for those
folks so that's what that's generally
what I feel I think that the where this
debate is going where the conversation
is going around the cheating stuff is
just weird to me because what you're
hearing a lot is well because there's
cheating this shows that we should not
have high-stakes tests because when you
put these high stakes you're making
teachers cheat that is so demeaning to
the teachers across this country that I
know you're implying that because you're
putting you know because there's
pressure that they're gonna do the wrong
thing there's pressure every day in a
teacher's life forget forget tests for a
moment because teachers know that the
future of their kids their students rest
in their hands so they feel that
pressure every single day and they're
not gonna make crazy decisions and you
know be cut just because of they feel
that pressure so I feel like that's
that's part of the problem that's going
on in the education debates these days
that is becoming sort of these very
polarized extremes that because you're
seeing some of this happen then we
should get rid of standardized tests no
you should put the right security
measures in place so that I feel like at
the end of the day here's the thing
there are people out there who are sort
of very anti testing right now and I
actually understand exactly where these
people are coming from because I can
tell you as a parent I have
kids and last year when my younger
daughter was in fourth grade she started
coming home in late April and I'd say
well where's your homework and she'd say
I don't have any homework anymore in
fact we're hardly going to school
anymore we're only going on field trips
cuz the TCAP is over that's the state
test where we live and I I thought oh my
gosh this kid is saying this to me right
if I was just a normal parent who didn't
know anything about education reform I
would hate that test
I wouldn't you don't even have to tell
me anything about it I'd be like why are
we creating an environment where we're
communicating either directly or
indirectly to kids that after the test
is over learning stops cuz that's
somehow all-important so I get the the
the feelings of the sort of anti testing
because when you have experiences like
that that makes you not want to like the
test at the other on the other side of
the equation though we have to have
standardized consistent ways of
measuring whether or not children are
learning whether or not they're learning
they're able to do you know what what
they should do for that grade level so
should we have and standardized tests
though they are not perfect or one way
to do that so do we need them yes should
they be the end-all be-all the thing
that we all go to school around every
absolutely not so what we need is a
balancing the equation just around with
the cheating stuff etc you need you need
balance you need reason you need
rationale when you are talking about the
policies because where people are on the
extremes that makes absolutely no sense
yes hi Michelle I'm amber I'm a second
year MBA I'm a graduate of DC Public
Schools and a former TFA Corps member
Houston 2008 I particularly like your
idea of public education as a great
equalizer
um one might argue though by virtue of
us being here at Stanford that we are
the winners in that equation so my
question to you is how do you get people
involved in the public education debate
and I guess the movement particularly
considering most people that leave here
might not go into the education sector
or if we end up in banking finance
consulting with it what might have you
it's
easier to say that's a very difficult
problem to solve I'm gonna put my kids
into public our private school and
forget the issue yeah so that's a great
question and one that that vexes me
every day because take for example
business folks right the vast majority
of business people that I run into on a
daily basis say to me you know Michelle
god bless you you know
Godspeed keep doing the work that you're
doing I mean it's just amazing and I say
great do you think you could sit on my
board or help me and oh no right so and
literally if I had a dollar for every
person who told me this like students
first would be set for a long time and
it's and it's frustrating but at the
same time it's understandable right if
you have a CEO of fortune 500 company
who takes a stand on education and then
the unions or whoever like come after
why are you supporting students first
why are you taking a stand on this issue
let's boycott the company their stock
prices go then they're not actually
fulfilling their fiduciary
responsibilities to their organization
so while they may think that education
is important it's not worth it for them
to take it on because they have other
stuff to worry about day to day right so
that I think makes a whole lot of sense
to me and you can't begrudge people for
that but that said I think that part of
the the the dynamic that we need to
create is getting people not just
business people parents who have their
whether they have their kids in public
school or not to understand that this is
an issue that is going to impact all of
us in the long run right because how you
get people involved in a movement
typically is if it impacts their
day-to-day life right I mean people are
busy every day come out to a meeting
come to the Capitol write a letter I
have 52 million things to do I can't fit
that in unless you say your kid is not
gonna be able to go to this Ben I will
clear my calendar to make things happen
and part of what we haven't been able to
do for the vast majority of Americans is
show them how weather getting involved
in public education
in this fight or not is gonna impact
their livelihood their day-to-day life
right it seems too far removed right now
and that's what we've got to kind of
connect the dots on but just a quick
thing this is so for employers and
business people fifty percent of of
employers in a recent survey said they
could not find people in their applicant
in their candidate pool who had the
skills and knowledge that they needed to
fill mission-critical jobs in this
economy with this kind of an
unemployment rate you have people who
have jobs and they're saying they can't
find people to fill them that is crazy
that means that we are not we don't have
an education system that produces kids
with the skills to fill the jobs that
are available and this disconnect is
only gonna widen as time goes on so if
we are creating a world in this country
where you know we might have the
Facebook's and the googles and whatever
but all the coders and the engineers are
half of em are being employed by people
and in India and China because that's
that's who has the skills that is a huge
problem for our country at large and so
connecting those dots is one of the
things I think we have to do in order to
crack this open and really get a broader
swath of people involved in this effort
oh I'll go back first and then you ask
sorry alright I'm my name is Alain
Enthoven and I'm a retired professor of
public management in this school and my
question is to ask for some
clarification in your thoughts about the
unions I read a lot about you know
excessive unfunded pension liabilities
about the inability to you know fired
sexual predators and all kinds of awful
stuff like that on one hand and then I
have an argument with my daughter who's
been in the Department of Public
Instruction in North Carolina and I say
the unions is a big problem and she says
what we don't have teachers unions in
North Carolina and we still have those
problems so help us understand your
thoughts on on that yeah people everyday
who say the unions are the problem and
if we just we didn't have the unions
everything would be better and the
unions the root of all evil
I actually don't agree with that at all
I believe that you
are doing exactly what they are supposed
to be doing right the job of the Union
the purpose of the Union existing is to
look out for the rights privileges and
pay of their members and they are doing
a bang-up job of that so you can't
begrudge them the fact that they're
doing exactly what they were created to
do you can't hate on that I don't
actually think that the union's doing
their job is the problem I think the
problem is that we have to date not had
an organized national interest group
with the same heft as a teacher's union
that's advocating on behalf of kids
because if you had that then you'd have
balance in the equation right and they
didn't you'd have a powerful force that
was out there saying the politicians if
you're gonna vote for this then you know
we'll support you if you don't but in
the absence of that counter force you
end up with a skewed landscape and a
skewed environment towards the special
interest groups and it's not just the
teachers union as testing companies its
textbook manufacturers you name there
are a lot of adults interests out there
in education who are just doing what
they're supposed to be doing so the
environment becomes skewed towards those
special interests when you don't have a
balance in the equation so that is what
I would say is the is the problem that
we need to be solving for not how are we
gonna change the unions because like I
said they're doing what they're supposed
to be doing I will say this that on some
issues I don't think the union is is
serving their members particularly well
and I'll take the pension issue as an
example if we don't do something to
solve the pension problems the systems
are gonna go bankrupt and people who are
relying on this in the long run are
gonna be screwed and that is not good if
you actually look at polling of new
teachers right so say you're gonna
create a new pension system and your
grandfather everybody who has more than
five years experience in right you can
keep your current benefits as they are
and you're just looking at people who
have not yet invested in the program
the vast majority of those people
actually they don't they're not
interested they wouldn't they don't
prefer a defined benefits program they
would prefer to have a portable more
flexible pension
so if moving towards a more flexible
system both solves the problem and is
what more teachers prefer new teachers
prefer then why wouldn't we move towards
that right so the that's the the kind of
circumstances where I think that that
unions need to sort of be moving along
with us because it's gonna better serve
their members and better serve sort of
the general school district operations
because like I said right now these
planned funded pension liabilities a
huge percentage of the dollars that are
being used to try to fill these holes
are being taken out of the classroom so
that doesn't benefit their current
members yes hi my name is Chen so my
expertise isn't in it and isn't in
education so please correct me if I'm
wrong but my understanding is that
socio-economic level and parents
education level are probably the biggest
determinants of learning outcomes by big
margin by really wide margin so I was
wondering based on your experiences I
wonder how much of our problems with
education today are due to broken policy
and how much of it is because of deeper
more intractable social problems and I
think because of a kind of DC's unique
situation in terms of socioeconomic and
quality and also learning outcomes to
kind of uniquely positions to speak to
this so here's what I will say when kids
are living in abject poverty does it
make it harder for them to come to
school ready to learn every day
absolutely does it make it harder to
teach them effectively yes unequivocally
those are two realities but can we use
poverty as an excuse for why kids aren't
performing at no I honestly refuse to
believe that because if you look at the
research it is very clear that of all of
the in-school factors that exist the
teacher quality is the factor that has
the most impact on student achievement
levels so if you look at a recent study
that was done by Raj Chetty from Harvard
it showed that if a kid has just one
highly effective teacher in their
lifetime and their 12-year schooling
experience
that it increases their lifetime
earnings their likelihood of graduating
from high school and going on to college
decreases the likelihood that they'll
have a teenage pregnancy just one out of
the 12 teachers that they have just one
increases those things we know based on
the research that if you have three
highly effective teachers in a row it
can literally change a kid's life
trajectory four in a row and you can
actually close the achievement gap so
that's not saying that poverty doesn't
provide a huge obstacle and barrier and
challenge to our children every day but
what it does say is that there are
things that we can be doing within the
schools every day that can make a
significant difference in these kids
lives and when I say these things often
ask people say well you're blaming the
teachers you're putting 200 I'm not
blaming the teachers for anything these
problems don't exist because teachers
are doing one thing of it what I'm
saying is that if we look at the
situation that we're in now and we look
at the potential solutions I believe
that teachers are the solution to the
problems that we face if we know that
three or four highly effective teachers
in the world can change a kid's life
trajectory why shouldn't we be aspiring
as a nation to make sure that every
single kid has a highly effective
teacher in front of them every single
day
that's not anti teacher that's just
that's just wanting to put every kid in
a in an environment where they are most
likely to be successful and III think
that that being controversial whatever
it makes absolutely no sense to me we
have to know within every sector that
we're in but in particular in education
that what we do matters and I would say
this if you look any at any place in
history over any time period any country
or whatever the most effective strategy
that we know to break the cycle of
intergenerational poverty is not a
social program and what it's making sure
that kids are getting the education they
deserve hi Michelle thank you so much
for joining us and so there's a two-part
question the first the first part is and
what lessons can the u.s. learn from
some of the other education systems in
the world and the second question is on
behalf
of the view from the top team and we
like to close with the question that we
all get asked as we apply to the
Business School which is what matters
most to you and why so what lessons can
we learn I just finished reading a book
that it hasn't come out yet but it's
gonna be out shortly
that's called the smartest kids in the
world and how they got that way and it's
a book written by an American journalist
who has been sort of in the she wrote a
big piece about me when I was the
Chancellor and she got sort of inundated
with all this you know Wow I see he's
doing XYZ so she started hearing you
know from people who are saying well we
need to do what Finland is doing we need
to do it South Korea is doing and so she
decided to go to Finland South Korea and
Poland to figure out what those systems
are doing and I the book is fascinating
because it actually tells us a lot about
what we shouldn't shouldn't be doing we
should not be trying to replicate a
situation like South Korea those people
are crazy those are my people so I can
say this we're a little crazy Koreans
have no moderation we're like for nuts
and you know look everything is focused
on like nuts anyways so we should not do
that but we also can't can't continue to
sort of believe you know what if kids
are poor they face too many challenges
there's nothing that we can do to
overcome the pot you know the challenges
of poverty and therefore we're gonna
throw our hands up that's not the right
answer either right and so what I think
she serve called out of the various
countries that are doing quite well is
that there is number one a very very
strong focus on teacher quality and a
lot of these countries do this on the
front end by not allowing anybody but
it's the highest achieving people to
actually become teachers and go into
schools of Education right and then
holding them to up to a high standard
throughout so that's one piece a very a
curriculum that is very very sort of
focused on having high standards for all
kids is another piece to it and then
having accountability at all levels so
not just of teachers and of
administration but of students to to say
look we're gonna hold you accountable if
you're not doing the right things so I'd
say those are some of the lessons that
we can learn from from other countries
and again if we if we do things in
moderation I think we can actually
vastly improve where we are as a nation
your second question was what is most
you and why what matters most to you and
why I would say that what matters most
to me is kids I mean this is what this
is what makes me get up in the morning
it makes me want to fight every day for
what is in their best interest because
so I now that I run this political
advocacy organization I have a lot more
interaction with our elected officials
which is unfortunate in a lot of ways I
was not too long ago talking to one of
them who said you know how much nah I
get it you you your policies make you no
logical sense to me and I'm not against
them at all he said what you need to
understand is if I vote for this bill in
the way that you want me to you have to
understand I'm gonna go back home and
then the the teachers are whoever are
gonna be picketing in front of my office
and those are my constituents and I have
an obligation to serve them and I said
you absolutely do I said but when you're
talking about your constituents you need
to think about all of your constituents
and at the end of the day you also have
an obligation to serve the children of
your district and guess what they don't
vote they don't contribute to campaigns
and they don't organize rallies on your
office so if you're just moving and
turning towards where the voices are
loudest necessarily that means you're
gonna be turning your backs to kids and
your background kids and that is
unacceptable
you have to be able to do this and this
is what I believe I believe so strongly
in what children are capable of doing I
did when I threw out my entire term as a
Chancellor in DC and
never made a substantial decision
without talking to kids and engaging
them in the policies because despite
what all the adults were always saying
and the arguments that we were having
the kids were the ones who had the most
insightful rational reasonable
conversations and debates I kid you not
because we're always like yeah
and then you know go back and further
each other you're right we're all right
but this is what so they could actually
do this in a way that that adults
couldn't the problem is we don't listen
to them enough in my opinion and in the
other thing that I believe very strongly
is there is nothing that is more worth
fighting for than the future of a young
person so kids without a doubt most
important thing thank you
[Applause]
[Music]